zone europe
bonjour et bienvenue dans une europe /
sensation une émission enregistrée au
parlement européen de bruxelles est
réalisée en association avec tv 78 voici
le sommaire de ce nouveau numéro faut-il
lever les brevets sur les vaccins contre
le coc vite 19 pour les rendre
réellement accessible à tous dans le
monde les enjeux du pass sanitaire
européen dans quelques instants je
recevrai l'eurodéputé belge marque
bottega l'histoire de l'europe valéry
giscard d'estaing était connu pour son
engagement en faveur de la construction
européenne
nous reviendrons sur le parcours de
l'ancien chef de l'état les expressions
populaires ne pas être intelligent les
danois disent ne pas avoir inventé
l'assiette creuse que dit-on ailleurs
c'est ce que nous verrons à la fin de
cette émission mais avant que fait
l'europe dans notre région un exemple
tout de suite
zone robe l'europe dans ma région
bonjour à tous aujourd'hui dans cette
émission je reçois ursula séraphin
bonjour bonjour alors vous êtes la
directrice de la maison de l'europe de
paris pour faire un petit point sur
votre parcours entre 1990 et 2003 vous
étiez coordinatrice des activités de
fondations journalistes un organisme
spécialisé en affaires européennes vous
avez ensuite intégré confrontations
europe en 2003 jusqu'en 2010 et vous
êtes donc depuis cette date directrice
de la maison de l'europe d'où vient cet
intérêt justement pour l'europe pourra
pour notre union européenne écoutez je
suis un peu tombé dans le dans le bain
sans préméditation
c'est à dire que bon étant donné que
j'ai un certain âge et que à l'époque il
n'y avait pas vraiment des q2 européenne
j'étais je me suis destiné plutôt à être
journaliste je suis polonaise d'origine
et puis un peu naturellement les postes
qui s'ouvraient à moi
était liée à l'union européenne parce
que vous avez cités la fondation
journalistes en europe qui était une un
centre de formation pour les
journalistes du monde entier pour les
sensibiliser sur l'union européenne et
leur donner les clés de compréhension de
fonctionnement de l'union européenne
d'ailleurs bon nombre d'entre eux était
correspondant auprès des institutions
européennes donc si vous voulez après
j'ai j'ai évolué dans ce dans ce monde
et changer de poste mais tout en gardant
ma ma spécialisation qui était le
fonctionnement de l'union européenne
alors la maison de l'europe de paris
fait partie des 49 présente en france
donc c'est un espace public européen
elle est faite pour informer les
parisiens et les franciliens sur les
enjeux européens mais aussi pour
promouvoir la citoyenneté européenne
pour ce faire justement vous organisez
ce qu'on appelle des formations à
l'europe expliqué me en quoi ça consiste
c'est vrai la maison de l'europe elle
fait partie de différents réseaux et
notamment du réseau des maisons de
l'europe en france mais aussi des
réseaux européens des maisons de
l'europe
il ya une association qui est basée à
cologne qui gère donc le réseau européen
des maisons d'europe et
oui disons que l'idée principale des
maisons de l'europe c'est de fournir aux
citoyens les clés de compréhension du
fonctionnement et de l'histoire de
l'union européenne ce que longtemps on a
on n'avait pas dans les programmes
scolaires de l'enseignement spécifique
sur le fonctionnement de l'union
européenne aujourd'hui ça existe un tout
petit peu mais disons que les maisons de
l'europe sont un peu en support
pédagogique pour les enseignants
pour expliquer le fonctionnement de
l'union européenne
pour cela nous proposons différentes
formations nous sommes agréés par le
ministère de l'éducation par le
ministère de la jeunesse par l'académie
de paris et on en perd en région ile de
france parmi les formations qui sont les
plus prisés pour pour les élèves c'est
évidemment la mobilité le fonctionnement
des institutions européennes et la
citoyenneté européenne
alors pour vous collaborez également
avec des clubs de la presse européenne
alors ensemble vous attribué chaque
année le prix de l'initiative européenne
il récompense les journalistes et les
médias pour la qualité de leur contenu
sur l'europe en quoi c'est important
d'avoir une médiatisation justement sur
ce sujet là écoutez je crois que tout le
monde un peu d'accord sur le fait que le
traitement de l'information européenne
dans le média n'est pas vraiment
suffisant on consacre pas énormément de
temps à expliquer aux citoyens comment
ça se passe la plupart du temps ça
change petit à petit parce que en fait
les associations européennes
se sont mobilisés pour sensibiliser les
médias notamment des médias nationaux
sur ces sujets mais
le déficit est là on consacre pas on
peut compter sur la main du sur les
doigts d'une main le nombre des missions
qui sont consacrées à l'europe d'où nous
on quelque sorte on débusque les les
journalistes ou les médias qui ont pris
le temps d'expliquer
correctement excusez moi le mot
correctement mais
le fonctionnement des institutions
européennes
l information sur sur l'europe la
plupart du temps on la traite encore une
fois quand même comme un bouc émissaire
mais comment ces prix sont attribués
justement
alors nous avons donc on s'est associé
avec le club de la presse européenne qui
réunit les journalistes correspondants
des médias européens
à paris et en france
et puis on
le jury donc les journalistes du club de
la presse la maison de l'europe de paris
et son conseil d'administration font des
propositions
sur
voilà sur la base de notre de nos
recherches et on décide
collégialement voilà sur
l'attribution du prix bon ça va changer
probablement
à partir de l'année 2000 21 on est en
train de de voir aussi comment élargir
le pli le prix à à des plus jeunes et
notamment à des écoles de journalisme et
des étudiants en journalisme pourquoi
c'est important de ramener l'europe au
plus près des habitants
tout simplement pour que pour coller les
citoyens s'approprient
l'europe
j'ai toujours en tête cette phrase d'un
fonctionnaire européen que j'ai eu la
chance de rencontrer au parlement
européen qui était français qui était un
fonctionnaire du zinc d'une ancienne
école et qui considérait que la
construction européenne c'est une
construction politique
et il disait toujours mais oui les
citoyens se sont appropriés
l'union européenne l'inconvénient c'est
que ils se sont approprié cette union
européenne de manière négative
c'est-à-dire l'euro a augmenté le prix
la pac a détruit l'agriculture
les
délocalisations ennuis à la au secteur
industriel etc etc c'est à dire que on
parlait de l'union européenne toujours
d'une manière négative et
donc nous notre idée c'est
pas être
[Musique]
les promoteurs faire la promotion de
l'union européenne mais donner des clés
pour que les citoyens puissent se faire
une opinion par eux mêmes d'avoir un
esprit critique par rapport à
l'information
véridique qu'on peut leur donner parmi
ces clés justement dans votre maison de
l'europe est aussi ce qu on appelle un
centre europe direct est-ce que vous
pouvez nous expliquer en quoi ça
consiste et guerrière d'intérêt mais
c'est alors le centre europe direct
c'est une labellisation de l'union
européenne et là était bon la maison de
l'europe porte cette labellisation
depuis 2008 mais en 2020 et les elle a
été renouvelée donc comme quoi
la commission européenne nous fait
confiance à notre association
elle a été renouvelé pour cinq ans et
donc nous avons pour objectif justement
d'avoir cette mission d'information des
citoyens l'histoire de l'europe dès 1957
alors qu'il n'est qu'un jeune député
valéry giscard d'estaing vote pour la
ratification du traité de rome créant la
communauté économique européenne un
engagement en faveur de l'europe qui
s'est poursuivi son parcours avec la
maison de l'europe et europe direct
sous drop
valéry giscard d'estaing est né le 2
février 1926 à coblence en allemagne
fils n'a en fonctionnaires il grandit au
sein d'une fratrie de cinq enfants
diplômé de l'école polytechnique et de
l'ena de la promotion europe de 1951 il
commence sa carrière au sein de
l'inspection générale des finances en
1956 il s'engage dans la politique et
est élu député du puy-de-dôme il est
nommé en 1962 ministres des finances et
des affaires économiques dans le
gouvernement georges pompidou
1962 1966 en 1969 il est à nouveau nommé
à cette même fonction dans le
gouvernement de jacques chaban delmas
puis en 1972 dans celui de pierre
messmer élu président de la république à
48 ans très formateur et moderniste il
prône une société libérale avancée son
septennat 1974 1981 est marquée par un
bon nombre de changements abaissement de
la majorité à 18 ans légalisation de
l'avortement divorce par consentement
mutuel ou encore simplification du
protocole de l'elysée pro européen
depuis toujours valéry giscard d'estaing
travail à un rapprochement durable entre
la france et l'allemagne l'entente avec
son homologue allemand helmut schmidt
mais dans la création du système
monétaire européen précurseur de l'euro
valéry giscard d'estaing a s'affirme
également comme un défenseur du
multilatéralisme initiateur du g5 il en
s'engagent pour une coopération accrue
au niveau européen et un nouvel élan
politique des institutions européennes
il supprime les sommet européen sorte de
réunion informelle des chefs d'état et
instaure le conseil européen
c'est également sous son mandat qui est
décidée l'élection au suffrage universel
direct du parlement européen en 1979 ont
lu les premières élections européennes
remportées par l'udf le parti du
président qui portent simone veil à la
présidence de l'institution après sa
défaite aux présidentielles de 1981 il
est élu à strasbourg où il préside le
groupe centriste du parlement européen
et c'est le sens de la commission
institutionnelle puis de la commission
économique monétaire et de la politique
industrielle au coeur des négociations
sur le traité de maastricht et sur
l'union monétaire il défend l'idée d'une
europe politique et d'un achèvement de
l'union monétaire en tant que président
du mouvement européen international son
engagement européen le mène à la
présidence de la convention sur l'avenir
de l'europe dans les travaux mène à la
création d'une constitution pour
l'europe signé en 2004 dans la
ratification échoue en france et aux
pays-bas c'est là inspira le traité de
lisbonne de 2007 valéry giscard
d'estaing tu défends l'idée d'une europe
dépassant les nations unies fiscalement
avec un budget commun élu en 2003 à
l'académie française en tant qu'écrivain
il aura continué toute sa vie comme ils
le défendent est dans son discours
devant la convention sur l'avenir de
l'europe en 2002 à rêver d'europe le 2
décembre 2020 valéry giscard d'estaing
meurt à l'âge de 94 ans dans sa
propriété de ton nom le loir et cher
sonos robe l'invité politique
je reçois aujourd'hui marque boeing à
bonjour bonjour alors vous êtes
eurodéputé belge membre du groupe de la
gauche au parlement européen vous êtes
membre de la commission de l'industrie
et de la recherche et de l'énergie alors
c'est pas la première fois que vous
venez d'en zone europe pour parler de la
gestion de la crise sanitaire par
l'union européenne à l'heure où nous
enregistrons cette émission 65% de la
population de l'union est entièrement
vacciner alors est ce qu'on peut dire
déjà que cette mission de vaccination
est réussie
65% c'est bien je dire en soi après il
ya des grandes inégalités au sein de
l'europe je pense au sein de mon pays
aussi mais ce que moi m'inquiète c'est
que on a une situation où mondialement
les inégalités sont absurdes et quand je
dis absurde en fait c'est révoltant et
c'est dangereux donc le british medical
journal qui a un journal médical
prestigieux parle même où s'interroge
sur un crime contre l'humanité pourquoi
parce que dans d'autres pays notamment
des pays à bas revenus il ya souvent que
même pas 3 % de la population qui a été
vaccinée et c'est dramatique parce que
vous savez le virus n'a pas de
frontières ne connaît pas de frontières
plus le virus circule plus il ya des
variants et vous savez qu'en europe on
sera pas en sécurité si demain il ya
peut-être un variant qui échappe aux au
vaccin est donc ce manque disons d'avoir
où cet échec à voir garantit un accès
universel à ce vaccin c'est aujourd'hui
le problème fondamental alors est-ce que
la stratégie vaccinale c'est finalement
la plus efficace en tout cas la
stratégie vaccinale à très grande
échelle en vaccinant toutes les
populations en tout cas au niveau
européen est ce que c'est la plus
efficace et est ce que finalement on a
le droit de critiquer cette stratégie
est d'avoir un autre point de vue est ce
qu'on ait entendu quand on pense
autrement on doit forcément ont critiqué
cette stratégie je veux dire moi je vous
pointe déjà les inégalités et ses
inégalités ne sont pas des fatalités je
ne lirai pas quelque chose qui nous
vient du ciel qui nous tombe dessus
abacha il ya des inégalités non nous
savions à la base déjà au début
qu'aucune entreprise n'aurait la
capacité de produire suffisamment de
vaccins pour tout le monde et donc on a
demandé un transfert de technologie une
ouverture du brevet etc ça ne s'est pas
fait l'union européenne est aujourd'hui
au niveau mondial l'opposant plus fort 2
cette mesure là donc le fait d'être des
partages des technologies et des brevets
alors bien sûr qu'il faut la critiquer
parce qu'en face de ça on voit big
pharma donc les grandes entreprises
pharmaceutiques qui font des milliards
des dizaines de milliards de bénéfices
et donc il s'agit pas de dire qu' ils
sont en difficulté qu'il faut aider les
entreprises non il faudrait aujourd'hui
en pandémie garante et la santé publique
évidemment ça vient avec toute une série
d'autres mesures qui doivent être prises
par rapport aux soins de santé primaire
par rapport à la prévention par rapport
à l'éducation à la santé etc donc ce
n'est pas que la stratégie vaccinale qui
est importante mais qui a un angle mort
très fort qui est celui d'eads et du
manque de vaccins disons dans dans les
pays du sud à faible revenu justement
les premiers cas qui ont été déclarés en
europe c'est janvier 2020 le 11 mars de
l'année dernière 11 mars 2020
l'organisation mondiale de la santé a
qualifié la situation de pandémie
carrément quels ont été les moments clés
de la gestion de cette crise à quel
moment est ce qu on a commencé à en
parler finalement au parlement européen
et est ce qu'on en a pas parlé un peu
tard parce qu'on a commencé à voir les
choses se passaient en chine depuis la
france ou même la belgique on sait au
début déconfinement l'italie le nord de
l'italie était confiné on voyait ça de
très loin alors que finalement c'était
déjà très proches oui je pense que en
belgique encore quelques semaines avant
le confinement on a eu une ministre de
la santé qui a insinué que c'était
finalement une petite grippe 1 et on n'a
pas pris au sérieux en tant que que le
gouvernement donc pas nous
particulièrement faire moi pas tellement
parce qu'on n'est pas au gouvernement on
est à l'opposition mais les
gouvernements n'ont clairement pas pris
la mesure n'ont pas pris au sérieux ce
qui est en train de se passer on a pensé
c'est ce que ricciardo c'était par
manque de moyens non je pense que
c'était par manque 2 à 2,2 de
considération pour le reste du monde
donc ritcher totten qui est éditeur en
chef de rédacteur en chef de l'insset
qui est une revue notre revue médicale
prestigieuse a dit qu'en fait on a
regardé avec mépris les pays asiatiques
où ça se passait on a dit ouais ça se
passe en chine mais bon toute manière
c'est là est loin ici c'est loin d'ici
ça restera là c'est un député de groulx
les rentes on n'a pas pris au sérieux et
quand c'est pour ça que je dis quand on
a une ministre encore quelques semaines
avant confinement généralisée jamais vu
kidioui finalement est ce que c'est bien
pire qu'une grille c'est évidemment le
symbole ou la preuve qu'on n'a pas pris
au sérieux comme on n'a pas voulu
prendre au sérieux le besoin d'avoir des
traitements et des vaccins accessibles à
tous partout dans le monde le plus
rapidement possible et on a dit oui on
va investir sur le vaccin on va mettre
le paquet mais on ne va pas demander que
le vaccin soit accessible à tous tout de
suite justement à l'heure où on parle
d'une troisième injection de vasques de
vaccins déjà aux états unis mais même
déjà au sein de l'union on parle de 25 %
de la population mondiale qui est
totalement vacciner majoritairement les
pays riches c'est ce que vous disiez
tout à l'heure et sur le continent
africain seuls 5% de la population
serait totalement vacciner alors la
commission européenne est à l'initiative
d'une d'une installation d'une
construction d'une usine d'havas kz1 sur
le continent africain alors thierry
breton commissaire européen a annoncé
plus d'un an un an et demi pour
construire cette usine est ce que c'est
pas déjà trop tard mais évidemment
d'abord il ya des usines qui existe qui
pourrait fabriquer le vaccin si on
libérait le brevet et s'ils ont partagé
la technologie donc activer la capacité
de production existantes est un défi et
est quelque chose qui devrait se faire
mais pour ça il faudrait ouvrir les
technologies ou partager les
technologies et le brevet et sa
l'industrie pharmaceutique l'union
européenne ne veulent pas le faire et
donc est ce qu'ils font ils disent ben
va construire une nouvelle usine qu'on
va financer et qui appartiendra ou dont
le contrôle final sera aux mains des
multinationales européennes 1 pour ne
pas participer à importer en europe des
vaccins qu'on va construire en assurer
sait déjà c'est ce qui s'est fait
maintenant avec johnson & johnson en
afrique du sud on vous voyez que en
afrique du sud il ya un manque de
vaccins on à paris on voit que nous
l'union européenne a un deal avec
johnson & johnson pourquoi parce que on
a l'argent de dire ben vendez vos
vaccins à nous chez nous et donc ont
importé on a on apporte des vaccins de
johnson & johnson en europe
en fait en niant ainsi le droit à
l'accès au vaccin aux sud-africains et
donc ça se fait c'est hyper cynique
parce que ce qui se passe c'est pas
c'est pas une question de est ce que les
européens au plus haut - droits que les
appliquer en vaccins la question c'est
est ce que on a droit à la santé ou est
ce qu'on préfère les profits des
multinationales la contradiction elle
est là et donc tant qu'on ne bouge pas
sur cette position dit ah non le profit
d de big pharma est sacro saints mais on
n'y arrivera pas il ya des gens qui vont
continuer de mourir est ce que en
entendant emmanuel macron au début de
cette crise d'hier nous sommes en guerre
finalement c'est pas un peu
contradictoire avec le fait de ne pas
libérer
les façons de faire les vaccins de ne
pas libérer ça pour les africains même
le monde entier et bien sûr mais je
voulais quand même rappeler que même au
sol avant de relayer une président de la
commission européenne a dit en avril
2020 donc il ya plus d'un an que le
vaccin devrait être un bien commun
universel
après elle a évidemment fait marcher
mais monsieur macron aussi je m'accroche
à dix les brevets on n'y touche pas puis
il a dit après que joe biden président
américain a dit oui moi je suis en
faveur d'une levée des brevets monsieur
macron à tout d'un coup dit ah oui mais
moi aussi bien entendu et puis ensuite
il a encore changé de position quand il
s'agit de négocier vraiment donc vous
voyez bien que les intérêts sont là mais
sous la pression du public sous la
pression populaire parfois ils doivent
ils doivent céder un peu ils doivent
bouger un peu et donc moi je compte
beaucoup sur cette pression populaire
pour faire changer le rapport de force
vous parlez de pression populaire depuis
le 1er juillet dernier un pass sanitaire
européen appelé certificat covin
numérique de l'union européenne est
entrée en vigueur dans l'ensemble des
pays membres mais son utilisation fait
débat dans les divers pays à lhassa a
été lancée par le danemark 1 dès le mois
d'avril ce mouvement est élargie suivi
avant d'être harmonisées au niveau
européen mais l'utilisation diffèrent
d'un pays à un autre on en discutait
juste avant c'est plutôt très stricte en
france ou encore en italie c'est un peu
plus souple en belgique ou encore en
roumanie où ça simplice anneaux ça ne
s'applique qu'à l'intérieur ou à des à
des rassemblements de plus de 1000 1500
personnes est-ce que vous pensez que
tout d'abord c'est une solution pour
réduire la transmission du virus et est
ce que vous comprenez la population qui
dit que ça ça brade les libertés
individuelles mais il ya évidemment
je trouve d'abord avoir effectivement
vous dites dans différents pays
européens ça se passe de manière
complètement différente donc il ya des
pays qui sont extrêmement strictes je
pense que la france est à peu près le
pays où c'est le plus strict ou même
pour s'asseoir en terrasse on a besoin
de montrer le pass il y en a il ya des
pays qui demandent juste le le passe à
l'entrée du pays donc le pass européens
d'ailleurs pas pas autre chose donc
voilà déjà là on voit qu'il ya une
gestion différenciée comme on l'a vu
tout au long de cette crise jeudi ya
jamais eu au niveau européen vraiment
une honte et un accord là dessus par
rapport à l'obligation du pass mais je
veux quand même dire que l'état est en
train de renoncer à certaines
responsabilités c'est-à-dire la
responsabilité de convaincre d'organiser
dans dans certains quartiers ou dans
auprès de la population
kiki qui hésitent qui doute et c'est
d'organiser des campagnes d'organiser de
convaincre vraiment pour parce que la
base de toute campagne de santé publique
doit être l'adhésion mais cette adhésion
requiert un travail des autorités et
requiert un travail d'un système de
soins de santé les soins de santé
primaires etc moi je veux pas peut-être
pas faire confiance à big pharma une
grosse multinationale mais à mon médecin
je veux faire confiance insistons
là-dessus rentrons dans le dialogue
convainquons et c'est hélas l'état et
les différents états malheureusement en
europe refuse rechignent à le faire et
alors et choisissent l'option plus
facile dévoila soit l'obligation
vaccinale mais qui sont des obligations
vaccinales cacher on peut pas en préface
le mans tient en partie on pourrait dire
ça mais le débat reste le même que ça
soit sur ce game place techniquement on
pourrait parce qu'en france c'est comme
ça mais dans d'autres pays c'est
différent donc la question se pose
vraiment différemment mettre la question
est ce que votre système de soin est ce
que vous voulez investir dans votre
système de santé créer l'adhésion ont
créé le tracing comme on dit aussi un
donc le suivi des gens est ce que
voulait réagir soul est sûre la balle
etc ou est-ce que vous dis non je fais
là la solution facile et match comprend
l'om est sain certainement a dit donc
l'organisation mondiale de la santé qui
a des risques effectivement par rapport
aux libertés d'attaché incertain comment
dire certains droits un certain statut
de santé et donc il faut certainement
être attentif à cela et moi je veux
insister sur le rôle que devrait jouer
l'état et s'il ya bien une chose qu'on
doit prendre de cette crise c'est que
nous avons besoin d'un système de santé
fort c'est-à-dire de première ligne mais
en général aussi unifier fort et alors
on devrait investir la dent dans nos
services publics pour dire la plus
jamais ce genre de pandémie mais ça je
ne vois pas ni l'état français ni en
belgique 7 7 pouces et dans un européen
et certainement pas au niveau européen
mais je m'attends à ce que la commission
européenne ne demande plus jamais un
pays de couper dans ses soins de santé
mais ce qu'elle a fait pendant dix ans
63 x et ben je m'attends aujourd'hui à
ce que la commission européenne aux plus
jamais le faire mais est ce que
finalement le parlement et l'union
européenne n'est pas une trop grosse
machine pour avancer face à une crise
qui avancent très rapidement un virus
qui mute très rapidement mais ça dépend
ce que ce que vous voulez je veux dire
c'est pas le parlement européen qui va
gérer la crise
c'est au niveau européen qui ont à gérer
justement ces négociations avec les big
pharmas absolument et je pense que vous
savez si le but des négociations avait
été on veut acheter ce vaccin au
meilleur prix aux meilleures conditions
dans toute la transparence et ses
terrasses aurait été une bonne chose
parce qu'on aurait été 27 pays face au
big pharma pour s'imposer mais le but
n'a pas été ça le but a été de dire on
va vous garantir vos profits en échange
on veut une petite priorité par rapport
à vaccin ça c'est pas du tout ce à quoi
devait servir c'est cette coopération
européenne est-ce que c'est l'échelle
moi je constate que tous les pays ont
suivi ces négociations tous les pays la
france était présente la belgique
étaient présentes l'italie l'allemagne
et c'est donc aucun pays peut dire que
c'est c'est uniquement la faute à la
commission européenne - je critique
fortement la gestion de la commission
européenne qui est celle du profit
d'abord plutôt que celle de la santé
d'abord mais les états les gouvernements
l'ont suivi ont contrôlé et donc c'est
la même logique qui domine au niveau
national en france ou en belgique ou
ailleurs et à la commission européenne
très bien merci beaucoup marketing à
d'avoir été mon invité dans une europe
je rappelle que vous êtes eurodéputés
belges eux membre du groupe de la gauche
au parlement européen et membre de la
commission de l'industrie de la
recherche et de l'énergie
zone europe expression d'ici et
d'ailleurs
alors tout autre chose à présent les
expressions populaires ne pas être
intelligent alors en france on dit ne
pas avoir inventé le fil à couper le
beurre alors comment est ce qu'on dit en
belgique
écoutez si on veut être
poli on pourrait le dire mais qu'est ce
qu'on pourrait dire encore je pense que
nous souvent les belges en est un tout
petit peu plus direct et je ne me
permettrais pas de d'utiliser sa science
sur vos antennes mais mais voilà on on
irait un peu plus aux francos je pensais
bien avec des expressions que je suis
sûr sont connus en france mais qu'on va
terre ici on va parler tout de suite que
dit-on ailleurs regardez les roumains 10
il est intelligent comme le mouton au
royaume uni ont dit
il ce qui signifie ne mettra jamais fait
la tamise aux pays bas ont dit ne pas
avoir inventé le film noir en espagne on
dit seul martin cap eric ouannes d'alors
pâlotte être plus belle quelqu'un euros
c'est lui qui utilise les banquettes du
tambour zone europe c'est terminé pour
aujourd'hui merci aux équipes techniques
du parlement européen de bruxelles vous
pouvez retrouver cette émission en
podcast audio et vidéo sur notre site et
notre application radio sensations et
aussi sur tv 78 rendez vous la semaine
prochaine très bonne soirée
zone europe / sensations
zone europe avec le soutien financier de
la région ile de france